[Music]
hey
welcome back it's time for drew's news
where we're serving the stories
thanks guys okay i have a
very special co-pilot today you may know
her
from 90s rom-com never been kissed she's
a high school senior
and future journalist it's josie geller
hi josie thank you for being here
thank you for having me your studio's so
beautiful
oh so is your ensemble
you know you didn't have to dress up
just for this it's
tv and it's the fanciest thing i own and
i never really got to wear it anyway
well why don't we make a new memory for
you in that dress
right now what do you think i'd like
that very much
so i understand that you want to be a
journalist
and i have to tell you i think you're
going to make a really good one
you want to practice with me yeah
absolutely
okay here we go first
up the story everyone is talking about
about who will be the next president of
the united states
george bush or michael dukakis
oh josie you've missed so much
a lot has happened since 1988. wait
don't tell me don't tell me who won
because my money's on michael dukakis
never underestimate an underdog have you
seen karate kid
yes all five of them
okay i'll go next so this next story is
a little pop culture for you
a fan recently took a selfie with harry
styles in the wild and people are
loving harry's new untamed look who's
harry styles
oh um he's an actor and a musician
and a performer and he's very cute girls
love him
you know what just think jordan knight
from nko tv
oh he's cute
we'll get focused now what do you think
josie all right
okay next i have a huge sports story for
you
cool totally cool graphics
okay the jets just made football history
when they beat the pittsburgh steelers
for the first time
ever they'd lost every game against the
steelers since 1970
but 1988 is gonna be the magic year
things are looking up for those jets oh
i just know it
yeah sure josie i love an underdog too i
know you do so
let's do it you know what go jets
oh my gosh i'm so sorry no it's okay i
just
sometimes you know when things go flying
at my face i get a little nervous
you know especially in this dress
i know i should have been so much more
sensitive to that
no it's okay don't worry you know and
it seems like i'm in really good hands
here i mean
this is a room full of doctors
your tv crew is all doctors
i mean right everyone's wearing a mask
oh josie there's so much that you have
to catch up on
and um i can tell you in the break cause
we're almost out of time can you at
least tell me in this future
world if no other girls get pranked by
the popular boy in high school who
throws an egg
out of the sunroof of his limo bad news
is
that type of stuff does still happen but
people are filming it and they're
putting it on this thing called the
internet
and then people get to watch it over and
over again
the internet sounds kind of like a high
school cafeteria but
worse because it lasts forever yeah that
is very astute josie
some high school bullies never grow out
of it some bullies never grow out of it
but
actually there is a lot of good there
out in the world
and because of the internet it can
actually get around a lot
faster and people who love
math and all sorts of things you know
can find each other
yeah people can find their people
and they can share their stories and
support each other across the world
it's pretty cool wow that sounds awesome
do you know if on the internet they
still call me josie grossi
yes they most definitely do
but the good news is
josie grossi is kind of like a merit
badge that you can wear really proudly
you're just trying to make me feel
better no it's true
a lot of people actually see themselves
in you
and we can all get in touch with our
inner josies
really
i guess that's pretty special yeah
it is josie thanks for being here and
reminding us
all about that thank you drew you know
what
let's make a new memory you want to
dance us into break
oh yeah
[Music]
you